Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Poggers! Huge Pog! Massive Pog!
So Leute, ich bin am Start. Falls ihr eben schon was im Stream gehört habt, dann weiß ich das nicht.
Der Kommentator ist am Start. 17 Monate Hyper Subscription hier.
Massive Subs.
So, die richtige E-Mode Größe ist entscheidend. So, perfekt. Exquisite.
So, also, mal gucken, ob das alles funktioniert.
Ja, Funst. Von der Benachrichtigung hier. He lacks critical information. Stream ist gar nicht live.
Jebaited. Aufzeichnung.
So, also, okay. Ich verrate euch mal kurz, was wir heute machen. Und zwar, ich hatte heute Rücksprache mit meinem Chef. Und mir ist aufgefallen, dass ich vor, das haben wir heute übrigens zum Glück nicht besprochen, dass ich ihm vor einem Jahr oder so erzählt habe.
Warte mal. Ich mach mal, also das hab ich ja, aber wir machen heute exquisite, classic Soundtrack.
Ah, yes. Für mehr Gehirnzellenstimulation. Ah, yes. Weil das ist mir eigentlich auf Dauer vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu anstrengend. Ich weiß nicht.
Wie konntest du den Soundtrack wechseln? Das ist schon fünfmal durchgelaufen in der Zwischenzeit. Also, und zwar, ich hab vor einer Weile mal vorgeschlagen, ich könnte mal so eine Skills Übersicht erstellen.
Wo ich mal so reinschreibe, wo ich exquisite Big Brain Skills hab. Ich hab gedacht, das können wir einfach im Stream machen.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt mal in mich gehen und mir überlegen, okay, was könnte man da alles hinschreiben? Cobol zum Beispiel. Cobol, äh, sehr gut.
Grills klären, Social Media Expert. Nee, realistische Sachen reinschreiben. Ähm, und mir ist was wirklich ZG aufgefallen, Leute. Richtig ZG.
Mess, also richtig, so hier. ZG ist mir gerade was aufgefallen. Und zwar sag ich dir was zu. Und zwar wisst ihr, was mir extrem ZG aufgefallen ist? Und zwar, dass es ein Plants vs. Zombies 3 gab.
Schon vor über, glaub ich, im dreiviertel Jahr released. Ich hab nichts von mitbekommen. Und das Game sieht dermaßen beschissen aus, dass ich mich frage, was hat EA da wieder gemacht?
Ihr wisst, dass ich riesen huge Fan bin von Plants vs. Zombies 1. Und jetzt guckt euch mal die Screenshots davon an.
Was ist mit denen los? Alter, was ist das? Wollt ihr mich verarschen? Ich mein, es hat sich zurückentwickelt. Es hat sich zurückentwickelt.
So, das ist Plants vs. Zombies 1 gewesen. Ich mein, jetzt mal ernsthaft. Was zum?
Das ist Plants vs. Zombies auf Wish bestellt. Was ist denn mit dir? Das kann doch nicht in der Ernst sein. Echt, das ist ein...
Das kann doch nicht in der Ernst sein. Guckt euch den Schrott mal an. Das ist der erste Teil. Wunderbar. Pixel-Grafik. Alles top. Super Game. Was ist denn das?
Das ist... Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll. Vor allem, warum haben die Nüsse überhaupt einen Lebensbalken?
Vorher hat man da erkannt, anhand wie die Grafik aussah, ob das gut oder schlecht war. So, und es wird noch schlimmer. Es wird noch schlimmer.
Das hört noch gar nicht auf. Das hört noch gar nicht auf. Nicht nur, dass das Gameplay übelst ranzig aussieht.
Sie haben auch noch so dämliche Level-Mechaniken eingebaut. Level deine Pflanzen auf und es wird noch schlimmer.
Es wird noch... Moment, Moment. Es wird noch schlimmer. Du kannst jetzt eine eigene... Guckt euch das mal an. Was ist das für ein... Was machen die mit dem Game, Alter? Was soll das?
So, und es wird noch schlimmer. Es wird noch schlimmer. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das irgendwo sieht.
What the fuck? Die haben auch noch Farmville oder sowas mit eingebaut. Man kann jetzt... Man kann jetzt die Stadt aufbauen mit Microtransactions.
Level your house, Microtransactions für Stadt ausbauen. Please. EA, wirst du dir jedes gute Game irgendwie versauen?
Was du sehen bist, Plants vs. Zombies 3, was schon vor einem Dreivierteljahr rausgekommen ist. Okay, das stimmt nicht. Es kam so eine Early Access Version raus und die Leute haben es geflamed as fuck.
Es kann doch nicht sein. Guckt euch das mal an. Das war so... Also ich will nicht sagen schön jetzt von Effekten oder so.
Ein schönes Game. Das war einfach handgemalte Pixel Grafik. Das ging. Das war wunderbar. Und was macht man draus? So eine hässliche Krütze mit irgendwelchen...
Was sind das überhaupt für 3D Models? Haben sie da sich irgendwie von DeviantArt... Waren sie auf Fiverr? Waren sie auf Fiverr und haben sich was machen lassen oder wie?
Meine Güte, ey. Ich krieg Anfälle. Wie kann man das so verkacken? Ich meine, der zweite Teil war schon deutlich schlechter als der erste Teil. Und warum war der zweite Teil schlechter?
Weil sie sich gedacht haben, anstatt motivierendes Gameplay ist genug, die Sachen frei zu spielen, hat man sich gedacht, nein, wir fucken die Leute ab und machen es jetzt mit Microtransactions.
Natürlich sind das 3D Models. Guckst du dir mal an. Doch, doch. Ich würd schon sagen. Doch, doch, doch, doch.
Deswegen hast du ja auch die komischen... Deswegen sieht das auch so eckig aus.
Das ist so schrecklich, Alter. Ich meine, der zweite Teil... Ich hab ja nicht gespielt lange, weil Microtransactions, das ging ja noch irgendwie auf.
Wie kann man, ey, wie kann man das wieder so verkacken? Ich versteh's nicht. Ich versteh's nicht. So, und das Witzige ist... Update History.
Das Witzige ist, die haben das Game released in Rumänien oder so. Irgendwie Ungarn-Rumänien. Und zum Test, Early Access.
Und danach, hier, die haben das quasi 25. Februar, also vor einem Jahr, in Rumänien oder so released.
Und danach haben die Leute es so geflamed, dass die das Game wieder runtergenommen haben und jetzt kann man es nicht mehr spielen.
Also die haben so extrem verschissen. Ich weiß nicht, was da wieder los war.
Das ärgert mich. Sowas ärgert mich richtig, ja. Das war so eine geiles Game. Der zweite Teil ging auch noch.
Das erste Garden Warfare war auch noch irgendwo in Ordnung. Auch wenn ich verstanden hab, warum und weshalb und naja, gut.
Aber das ist wirklich komplett... Das ist, das ist, äh... Ja. Echt Pain's Champ. Nee, war's nicht. Zumachen.
Dazu kann ich einfach nur, wenn ich das hier sag, wenn ich das hier seh. Kann ich einfach nur noch sagen. Ganz klar.
Piss dich, Aldo. Piss dich, Aldo. So, das geht an die E.
Gut jetzt aber hier zu aber so eine kacke wie man das so versauen kann
Was ist das shortcut umgeschlossene short tabs shift ctrl t
Sieht schrecklich aus
Exzellent
Das ist tatsächlich ganz nice ja das habe ich mir auch auf steam geholt ist tatsächlich ganz cool
Aber ich mag halt ist dass das das plans world zombie setting finde ich viel viel cooler
So ich mache mal kurz meine vm an oder vm wie die coolen leute sagen
Dann sollen sie meint wegen 16 bit grafiken aber gerade bei 16 bit grafiken sind wie findet ihr die schriftart ist sie nicht poggers
Warum ist heute lügenpresse kann mir das irgendjemand erklären wer hat diesen komischen wer hat es dem nightbot beigebracht?
Ja ja ich weiß ihr war es alle der chat wenn man den chat fragt wer es war dann war es immer jeder
I made this das ist das dümmste meme auf twitch ich verstehe gar nicht warum sich das so
Hat irgendjemand eine ahnung warum dieses I made this irgendwie so beliebt ist das ist total dumm
Aber gut twitch twitch und dumme chat memes da weißt ja schon bescheid soll man den kram von gestern wieder zumachen
Ppega vögel
erst mal update fahren erst mal
Nix zu mein was nix zu tun glaube ich nicht ja erst mal hier update bäm
bäm bäbä bäm update
So ich muss erst mal kurz meinen font wieder zurück stellen ok damit kann ich leben
Geh weg erst mal alles update zack zack
So das soll jetzt mal updaten genau also was wir heute machen ich gehe mal in mich ich speichere mir das mal
Ich gehe mal in mich und überlege mir mal detailliert was kann ich eigentlich
Ich meine ich kann euch jetzt schon spoilern viel viel ist es wahrscheinlich nicht
Aber ich wollte schon seit lange mal so eine liste erstellen wo drin steht was weiß ich welche programmier sprachen kann ich gut oder
Was was was kann man da was kann man da noch so reinschreiben so windows experte zb bin ich ja auch bekannt für also gerade dass ich mich mit windows
besonders gut auskennen powershell hacker
Drucker reparieren sowas ja mit shit mit shit kennen wir uns ja nicht so gut
Also in welchem
Drucker reparieren sowas ja mit shit mit shit kenn ich mich aus
ko boll ja ja ko boll ist natürlich klar
Ko ball ist ist einsteiger
90,999 prozent der weltbevölkerung wollen wir wetten
Ja, aber nur für für für massif konsultant geharr 250k im jahr dann mache ich domain migration easy
Ich habe übrigens am anfang gesagt ich sag noch was zu irgendwie genau zu was man das macht sie geschrieben hat wollte schon was zu sagen
Max ich arbeite auch teilzeit wie du muss sagen das war die beste entscheidung ja ist ist das beste teilzeit ist einfach nur
Ja ich arbeite 75 prozent 75 wie funktioniert das denn
Warte mal wie viel wie viel arbeite ich dann eigentlich lowbrane das überlegen wenn ich 100 prozent aber ein arbeit
Einen tag weniger weniger dann sind das 20 prozent also 80 prozent oder
Ich kann nicht mehr rechnen leute
Das 80 ja oder ja ja
Okay, dann dann bis noch ein bisschen weniger
huge huge muffs ja
Und ich brauche doch wieder ein bisschen nintendo gedudel dass es geht geht einfach besser
Immer
Einfach nice so deswegen verstehe ich gar nicht warum die brats auf der wald musik so pepega ist
Zumindest nicht zum zumindest ich fand sie langweilig so hier updates gemacht beim
So ich lasse das mal kurz updates durchlaufen und jetzt höre ich halt gucke ich noch mal kurz chat
Es ist echt so das ist genauso wisst ihr jetzt immer ernsthaft ich will jetzt nicht weiter drauf rumreihen wisst ihr warum das neue plans
Was ist so kacke aussieht die wollen keine leute verschrecken und man spricht den casuals
Dicht den casual der welt an das sind nicht also die die leute die mit sowas angesprochen werden sollen
Das sind welche das sind nicht die leute die man sich und die wir uns unser casuals vorstellen ja
Was sie damit ansprechen wollen ist das ist so wie mcdonalds ihr essen macht
McDonalds macht ihr essen auch nicht darauf dass es quasi gut schmeckt mcdonalds macht ihr essen darauf dass es einen möglichst geringen prozentsatz an leuten gibt die es nicht essen können
Das ist das ist das ist ja der trick dabei mcdonalds würde überhaupt keine vorteile davon ziehen wenn dies jetzt irgendwie besonders gut machen würden
Die die die sorgen einfach dafür dass es
Also du kannst ja auf der einen seite so besonders exquisite sachen machen wo du dann halt vielleicht nicht viele hast die das mögen aber die die das mögen die sagen halt
Boah das ist ja besonders fein
Und mcdonalds macht die umgedrehte taktik die machen es nicht besonders fein die machen es so dass es möglichst viele so wie farscht
Stuhlmusik im endeffekt dass das da ist die farscht stuhlmusik der mobile games was ihr da seht
Allem schinks tier 1 10 monat dankeschön poggers
Ja heute mal was skill skill ist irgendeine markdown skill ist da muss ich jetzt aber erst mal updaten für
Ne muss ich net aber ich mache es mal updaten
Ich habe mal früher fünf euro die stunde trucker repariert frag doch mal ob du bei hardware rad pc zusammen bauen kannst
Da verdient sie bestimmt mehr als fünf euro die stunde und ich habe gehört die suchen leute
Ist das ungoogle korn das ist kaum jem ja
Ja
Ja so sieht es aus es ist so es ist damit die mutter diese grafik sieht so aus damit die mutter und nicht nur die mutter das
Das das ist wie soll ich das beschreiben
Die mutter ist noch normaler casual das das sind so sachen die richten sich an leute die möchten möglichst wenig
Wenig haben wo sie anecken können ja also das ist ein spiel das ist garantiert auch also die sind auf so eine grafik gekommen
Weil die auch veganer nicht triggern wollen 100 pro
Das da machen die sich jeden scheiß gedanken heutzutage
Oder kann man halt manche sachen nicht machen
Ja
Ist es im endeffekt auch das ist das mcdonalds essen der mobile games oder die fahrstuhl musik der mobile games
Abzack sagt aber
Immer immer noch besser also man er p.m. Geht mir teilweise echt noch mehr auf den kicks floor the game stufe 1 sag ich schon für
den primes ab
huge
IQ increase ok
Gehen wir mal hier rüber hat er updates installiert massive sommer rebooten bm
Reboot schadet nicht guck ich ich mache mal ein reboot vielleicht kriege ich ein neues hintergrund bild von bingen
Es ist übrigens der einzige service den ich jemals von bingen verwendet habe und verwende verwende
Die daily daily image von bingen für meinen hintergrund das ist einzige
Also pack mein 6.0 nie das ist bingen markt vögel oder
Was ist das überhaupt
Er any ornithologen in der chat was sind das was sehe ich hier für vögel
Storch nee das ist kein storsch
Seine großeltern benutzen bingen
Wegen den schönen bildern ja genau
So leute wollen die mit plans was zombies drei ansprechen
So ok ich mache jetzt mal einen neuen ordner mk dir
Keck w3 weil keck w1 gibt es garantiert schon
Ah
Wusste ich dass es das gibt wusste ich das gibt keck wie gibt es schon
Keck wie gibt es schon keck weight und keck wie drei also so touch skills punkt md
Zack so sehr schön also
So ist jetzt müssen wir uns gedanken machen jetzt wirds jetzt wirds big brain also was schreibt man was schreibt man in so was rein
Was was schreibt man in so was rein also
Mima ich weiß ja nicht das soll schon was das soll schon was bisschen seriöses sein wo ich dann auch sagen kann ok hier lasst
Mal nachgucken
Das sind keine kraniche das weiß ich ja das kann sein ich kraniche sind das nicht das sind
5 hat bürz
Also also kann das nicht irgendwie die markt markt dauernd vorschau oder sowas konnte das nicht
Ah jetzt
Skillorts so
Also fangen wir mal an mit das mal überlegen mit was mit was fängt man gut an linux linux
Linux linux linux wir fangen mit linux an ok linux
linux linux
Zweite header draus linux ok
Also linux an sich
Was fällt da drunter schauss scripting kann ich gut
so bash zsh
so die standard dinger
Aber ich mach plus plus plus dahinter so für wie gut ich das kann
So was gibt es dann sonst auch was gibt es dann sonst auch für für
Sachen unter linux zu zu zu ahnung zu haben also red hat
cento s kenne ich mich super aus
Ubuntu debian kenne ich mich gut aus
Aus suse moment wir brauchen auch das passende image keck weh
Wie macht man noch mal ein image in markt dauernd
Image markt dauernd
Irgendwie irgendwas mit klammern ich kann mir das immer nicht merken
Irgendwas mit klammern na ah ja hier guck mal da
Poros
Und jetzt brauche ich keck wie keck weh image copy image link
So ha perfekt ob sie groß
Ja wunderbar haben wir das größer machen
Kameras kamer das irgendwie sie sie sie fetter machen oder so
Die kriegt man die vorschau größer ok markt dauernd preview vias code von size geht auch bestimmt irgendwie
von size markt dauernd preview
Microsoft
Also was extension markt dauernd von size ok
Quatsch was mache ich denn setting
Wo müssen wir hin extension
Mark dauernd ah ja hier von sides 20 bäm ah
Yes excellent excellent
Shit
Gut
Also red hat kann ich sento es kann ich ubuntu debian kann ich suse kann ich überhaupt nicht suse habe ich keine ahnung davon aber suse
braucht man ja auch nicht weil
Es ist sagt so
Was red hat red hat gleich elotrix was ach ach red hat
Jetzt habe ich es verstanden
Ok hat ein bisschen gedauert
Hier legs critical information hat ein bisschen gedauert ja
Ja
Ok was schreibt man denn in sowas rein ok win windows
Windows ja da fällt mir ehrlich gesagt nichts zu ein nächstes nächstes nächstes thema
Aber so wenn das habe ich keine ahnung von ok also
Linux kenne ich mich aus shell skippen sonst wie funktioniert auch wunderbar ich ich muss mir echt mal ein bisschen gedankt machen was man da
Alles rein was man alles reinschreibt also jetzt machen wir erstmal betriebssysteme so
Dann würde ich da mal sowas wie mal sowas wie klaut
Also klaut technisch kenne ich mich aus mit netlify ganz ok mit
Dings hier
Und
Wie heißen sie noch mal klaut flair voll vergessen alle klaut flair
Dann kenne ich mich aus ein bisschen mit aws allerdings nicht sonderlich gut mit mit google kenne ich mich auch
bisschen aus
So jetzt nach klaut auch dabei erkenne ich mich gut aus aber kann man überhaupt nicht vergleichen miteinander aber schreibe mal rein
Übrigens ausrufe zeichnen hetzener wer 20 euro gutschein haben will
Aber nur für neukunden
Es ja da kenne ich mir mittlerweile ganz gut aus weil auf der arbeit viel es ja machen
Ok wunderbar
Digital außen ja
Da kenne ich mich ganz gut mit aus habe ich lang verwendet
Was wird aufgeschrieben ich habe mal vor einem jahr meinem chef gesagt hey wie sieht es dann aus
haben wir nicht mehr sachen wo man ein bisschen was programmieren kann oder sonst wie
Und er hat gemeint ja müssen wir mal ein bisschen übergreifen gucken da habe ich ihm gesagt weißt du was ich schicke dir mal eine skillliste
Mit sachen die ich kann beziehungsweise sachen wo ich gerne was machen wo ich gerne mehr machen würde
Und ich habe es ist einfach jetzt ein ja über ignoriert und nicht mal dran gedacht
Ich habe mir gedacht ich mache das jetzt einfach mal im stream also ich gebe zu
Das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht das allerspannendste zum zugucken aber ich muss es eh machen
Und jetzt können wir auch im stream uns was überlegen
Ich war ich weiß noch nicht wie ich das ganze strukturiere ich schreibe jetzt einfach mal irgendwie ein bisschen was auf ja so
Cloud was zählt was zählt zu cloud sonst noch dabei ich würde sagen kubernetes und sonst wie das machen wir oder docker
Geschichten das machen wir dann später unter irgendwie defops tools oder sowas
Wie kommt man auf so viel cloud erfahrung einfach benutzen
Und eine firma haben die dafür geld ausgibt
Leute ich muss amazon sack
Metser
Die wichtige geschichte musst jetzt mal erledigt werden
Die ist aber echt gut leute empf spelungen
die ist aber echt gut leute
es war ohne scheiß also ich wollte jetzt hier nicht ein sinnloses rummeme machen oder
so
beste barbecue sauce hier die ist richtig scheiße kennt ihr jemand von euch
hell yeah ach ne falsches falsches kokona hier
die ist richtig spockers
warum ist das hier nicht richtig photoshopped oder sieht das auf dem glass auch so aus
aber die ist wirklich gut kann man nur empfehlen
sehr gut ist eine und das andere schließt sich ja nicht aus du kannst
ja eins mit senf essen und eins mit barbecue sauce außerdem muss ich sagen ich habe das
früher immer verkehrt gemacht ich habe barbecue sauce immer früher wie
ketchup verwenden also du hast barbecue sauce dabei geschüttet damit gegessen
bis ich irgendwann mal gecheckt habe das barbecue sauce eigentlich dafür
da ist dass man es drauf macht und damit dann auf den grill oder oder brät
oder sonst wie was oder zumindest schon beim zubereiten drauf macht und nicht
danach weil man kann sicherlich auch danach drauf machen schmeckt damit auch
gut das habe ich immer nicht kapiert weiß ich weiß nicht ob das wirklich so
der weißheitsletzter schluss ist aber ich glaube barbecue sauce ist dafür
gedacht dass man die bei der zubereitung schon drauf macht und dann schmeckt
die auch besser also schmeckt so schon geil aber wenn ihr die quasi mitgegrillt
hast schmeckt es noch besser auf fleisch wird bier gekippt das schmeckt
nicht also mir mir schmeckt das nicht ich mag bier aber an sich nicht ich
trinke nur 500 euro wein plus aber bier mag ich net
chat ihr bestimmt auch oder
übrigens ich muss mal wieder bestellen ich muss mal wieder bestellen bei meinem
lieblings italien shop und die haben auch hier wein aber ich trinke kein wein
ich trinke auch kein bier ich trinke eigentlich fast nichts alkoholisches da
kann man sich einfach mal easy sechs flaschen für 40 euro holen ja oder hier
oder hier 72 euro und 84 euro und so exzellent aber auch wenn man da nichts
bestellt an weinen kann man da exquisite nudeln bestellen die sind wirklich die
sind wirklich gut die nudeln bei denen die nudeln bei denen sind wirklich nice
guckt euch die mal an hier den font den font in visual studio endlich da da
habe ich drauf gewartet ja die sind wirklich poggers die nudeln und wenn man
gar nicht weiß was man bestellen soll dann bestellt man einfach probier
probierpaket probierpaket pass pasta und soßen dann kriegt man vier soßen
und vier mal nudeln ist wirklich sehr nice wirklich sehr schmeckt echt geil
das zeug von denen aber es ist halt ein bisschen teuer und ich glaube es ist nicht
jedermanns fall für nudeln und soßen quasi 37 euro auszugehen wurde beim
lidl 40 cent dafür bezahlt kann ich verstehen würde ich normalerweise auch
nicht jeden tag machen aber schmeckt wirklich gut also ich würde es nicht ich
würde es ganz ehrlich ich würde das nur zum probieren ich würde das nur zum
nur zum probieren mal machen normalerweise würde ich das nicht
würde ich das nicht bestellen weil die soßen sind so sind ok aber jetzt nicht
wahnsinnig geil ich bestelle lieber nudeln udel so das wird bei uns an
weihnachten immer an alle verteilt echt da dann kriegt ihr was gutes an
weihnachten bei uns gibt es an weihnachten vom betriebsrat so einen
komischen nikolaus und das war so ein nackischen nicht eingepackten nikolaus
schokoladen nikolaus
weil das stimmt ja gar nicht bei uns gibt es auch an weihnachten öfters mal
bei uns gibt es an weihnachten auch öfters mal sachen letztes mal gab es
gab es letztes mal nudel gab es das letzte mal stimmt nudel nudel und so
komisches salz was bei mir heute noch unten rum steht ich weiß nicht warum
salz aber nudel und salz gab es glühwein gibt es bei uns manchmal zu
silvester der schmeckt mir aber nicht wie gesagt leute ich trinke eigentlich so
gut wie nix das einzige was ich ab und zu ganz ganz selten mal trinke weihnachten
silvester ist tatsächlich bisschen bisschen wein aber ich bin kein großer
alkohol trinke ich mag bier überhaupt nicht und wein eigentlich auch nicht und
irgendwelchen harten krams so wodka und sonst wie auch nicht das einzige was ich
tatsächlich ganz gerne trinke ist whisky
aber dann auch nur ein bisschen war es
maxis schwerer alkohol darf man darüber eigentlich reden auf twitch
nee aber ich mag es nicht
habe ich auch schon mal habe ich auch schon mal gab falls sie ich bin mir nicht
versich lafroy oder wie man die ausspricht die haben ja auch alle
unterschiedliche sachen von von irgendwie hat mich nicht acht jahren bis
irgendwie dann rauf zu frag mich nicht 30 jahren für irgendwie 8000 euro die
flasche oder so es ist teilweise echt wobei sich das nicht lohnt
verkostigungs live stream nee mache ich net aber wie gesagt ich trinke nicht
nicht viel zeug
so ok weiter also was was was habe ich noch für messif messif skills lassen
überlegen was braucht man als als nächstes als nächstes mal programmier
sprachen aber progers progers ok jetzt muss ich mal in mich gehen was für was
für programmier sprachen krieg ich dann krieg ich denn gut hin vielleicht
sollte man progers unterteilen in back end und in front und ent vielleicht sollte
es einfach klein schreiben wieso cobalt immerhin ich würde sagen cobalt
fortgeschrittener ganz klar ich meine ich kann besser cobalt als 99,99
prozent der weltbevölkerung bin ich mir sicher weil die meisten leute können
gar keine programmier sprache und die die welche können können garantiert
kein cobalt ich meine ich habe mit cobalt immerhin immerhin schon mal
dateien eingelesen und geschrieben
kannst du mit dem horst live verkostum machen mit welchem horst
ach ich weiß wem du meinst du meinst denkst hier whiskey store ja genau der
den habe ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht ja den gibt es ja auch noch hat er nicht
einen zwei channel hat er nicht den zwei channel woran er erzählt hat klimawandel
liegt an sonnen aktivität gut ich meine man kann nicht immer einer
meinung sein ja außerdem es ist beim whiskey verkosten egal
so machen wir mal weiter also das weiß er hier für lulz ja also fangen wir an
es ist ab aber fangen wir mit was an was ich kann das kann ich gut so ruby ruby
kann ich auch gut
büton büton kann ich auch nicht gut mache ich zu wenig mit mache ich zu
wenig mit aber wenn ich was mache ist easy so
c plus plus c plus plus paint champ will ich nicht
das ist sogar synchron gescrollt mittlerweile paint champ noch es ist
keine programmiersprache aber noch es könnte man als technologie reinschreiben
ich weiß was ich was meine ich schreibe es einfach mal auf ich schreibe es
einfach aus nein aber beschreibe ich da nicht rein so ja war
du könntest 50 prozent machen für progress bar was
was ist das denn progress bar def
in einem minute was was was was sehe ich da
kann man das irgendwie einbinden oder wie du verdienst doch dein geld mit java
nähe zum glück nicht ich meine viele unserer software ist in java da mache
ich nicht mit den
die ausrufe zeichnen 50 prozent das klappt auch im leben nicht oder
nähe mit dem link dahinter
so das ist ja cool
oder das ist ja mal big brain alter
das ist wirklich next level shit hier
ok excellent das machen wir so so machen wir das java
fünf ach komm zwar ich kann java lesen und schreiben ich mag java aber nicht
der komfort sich ich ich kann das aber ich mag das nicht
ok c++ kann ich aber ich mag es absolut nicht aber ok es soll ja was ernsthaftes werden es
soll ja was ernsthaftes werden ok 60 ich meine ich hasse es da was mit was zu
machen aber ich krieg es mittlerweile ganz ich krieg das mittlerweile echt ganz
gut hin also auch wenn viele sachen noch böhmische
dörfer sind aber das ist normal in c++ 70 ruby ruby kann ich wirklich gut auch
wenn ich schon ganz lang nichts damit gemacht habe was passiert eigentlich
wenn ich jetzt 1000 reinschreibe
9000 poggers bringt ja zwar nix aber
cobalt 10 ich mein cobalt ernsthaft ja
puzzle meister dankeschön für den zapp ok lasst mal weiter überlegen was haben
wir noch für was haben wir noch für für neise für neise prognose sprachen was
kann ich dann noch go go kann ich mittlerweile tatsächlich ganz gut aber
ich drück mich immer was davor in go zu machen weil es einige sachen an go gibt
die mich nerven ich verwendet go immer nur dann wenn es gute libraries in go
gibt oder das ökosystem halt go erfordert ansonsten mache ich eigentlich
bogen um go weil es ist mir doch ein bisschen sehr minimalistisch in vielen
stellen wisst ihr es gibt zum beispiel eine sache die ich nicht verstehe warum
man warum man das 2021 rast habe ich auch mal ausprobiert ja können wir auch
gleich was dabei schreiben was habe ich aber zuletzt vor ein paar jahren gemacht
als es relativ neu war also was mich halt an go nervt ist zum
beispiel diese sache ich weiß zum beispiel ich kann mir einfach ums
verrecken nicht merken wie die wie die maps und tags ist in go es ist es ist
ganz schlimm also wenn du in go eine variabler anlegen willst
da musst irgendwie so int wie ging das ich kann ich kann es mir nicht merken ich
kann es mir einfach nicht merken so map so ich kann es mir einfach nicht
merken maps und tags go nicht mappo ja aber plus gleich geht nicht wenn es
global ist das war doch richtig was ich gemacht habe fast leute es war fast
richtig es war fast richtig guck mal es war fast richtig was ich gemacht habe
das ist aber auch eklig ist und tags aus dem kopf so also so das ist das ist eine
map zuordnung key value also sprich so was hier zum beispiel map 0 w gleich 1 so
und was ich halt was ich halt überhaupt nicht mag an go ist dass wenn man jetzt
zum beispiel sagen wenn man hat man hat einen int array ich finde diese sind
total und eingängig dann haben sie noch ihre komische slice syntax die noch mal
anders ist so und was ich halt ein bisschen doof
hin du hast in du hast in go einen array mit fünf elementen so in jeder
programmiersprache kannst du sowas machen array sagen wir jetzt irgendwie
keine nennen wir mal javascript filter element ich will alle elemente haben die
größer als zwei sind so neues ray gleich so das kannst du in nahezu jeder
sprache machen dies heute gibt nicht in go in go funktioniert das net weil die
sich gedacht haben vorschleife master race in go in go musst du dann in die
vor range war das so die syntax go for range
ja fast fast fast fast fast fast so das ist die syntax in go und die sind in
go richtig scharf drauf dass du alles verschleifst ja also so nach dem motto
wie array filter sonst wie ne gibt es nicht gibt es nicht nein mach mach
schleife von hand und ich finde auch dieses plus klar dieses doppelpunkt
gleich ein bisschen pains champing weil du kannst sachen mit wahr anlegen du
kannst sachen dann naja es ist wie gesagt ich finde go ist nicht so
konsequent in manchen sachen aber es ok ist ist in ordnung also kann man
verwenden ich finde so eigentlich kutteln damit
habe ich tatsächlich noch nichts gemacht das finde ich halt ein bisschen pains
champ in go aber ich mag go an sich also wenn ich die auswahl habe jetzt mal
ernsthaft wenn ich die auswahl habe machst du was in go oder machst du was
in c++ da können wir davon ausgehen ich werde ich würde jeden tag go verwenden
so machen wir weiter javascript so dumm es klingt mittlerweile kriege ich
javascript eigentlich ganz gut hin
auch wenn es immer noch ein paar ich habe eine null vergessen bei kobol du
meinst es muss so sein wie gesagt ich habe sie eben gesagt ich kann kobol
besser ich kann ich kann kobol besser als 9.99 pro welt der weltbevölkerung das
heißt aber bei kobol auch nix immer dieses c++ gebasche naja c++ ist ja auch
einfach zu basteln weil c++ kacke ist so als javascript kriege ich mittlerweile
auch echt ganz gut hin auch wenn es noch so ein paar sachen gibt die die mich
immer kringen lassen javascript ja zum beispiel objekte schleife objekte
oder oder was gibt es was gibt es noch so schön kringiges in javascript ich
meine gleich gleich gleich ist ja immer so ein bisschen so eine sache was gibt
es so schön kringige sachen noch in javascript immer pein die immer richtig
pein sind dass da auch wieder drei verschiedene variablen du kannst du kannst
machen du kannst konst machen du kannst einfach so zuweisen ja das ist ein
bissl inkonsequent aber es ergibt es ergibt in javascript sogar noch sinn
weil javascript eben gewachsen ist in den letzten jahren und dadurch dass es im
browser drin ist kannst du auch einfach alte sachen über bord schmeißen dass
dann sachen nicht funktionieren get burrito dankeschön twitch prime gaming
so type script muss ich ehrlich sagen ich habe ein bisschen was mit type
script gemacht aber ich blick aber weiter noch nicht wirklich gut durch
kommen wir mal html css in einem da bin ich echt nicht gut ich sag mal 50 also
gerade css gerade css habe ich echt da komm ich meine ich kriege wer ich kriege
webseiten frontend sind das ist kein kein ding aber ich bin gerade was css angeht
bin ich immer wieder überrascht wie easy man sachen in css machen kann wenn man
weiß was man macht ach moment hat er mir alles nicht beckent
lull keck wait
kennt ihr nicht die html das html beckent
wenn ich das meinem chef zeige dann bekomme ich den java kurs kann schon sein
o pp pp ja pp kann ich tatsächlich auch halbwegs brauchbar ich würde mal sagen
so 50 50 hat jemand meine frage an den chat hat jemand von euch auf meinem
battlefield 4 server gespielt damals wahrscheinlich nicht wahrscheinlich
nicht schon so lange her wahrscheinlich was was der max hatten battlefield 4
server gehabt und auf meinem battlefield 4 server hatte ich eine php ist der
zeite da konntest du auf max fps.de gehen
ich glaube slash battlefield 4 oder so oder hast du eine übersicht gesehen an
statistiken von leuten ja genau auf nitrado genau da hast du eine statistik
gesehen von kills und alle möglichen sachen von den leuten die auf dem server
gespielt haben und das war mit php gemacht mit laravel laravel 08 oder so
was damals es war glaube ich noch gar nicht raus das war wirklich das war
wirklich nice und was halt was halt das coole war oder was immer noch das gute
an am php ist das gibt es halt überall php du wirst kein host da finden php
maria db oder php mai sql das sind einfach die dinger die jeder wenn ihr
den den reutigsten letzten hinterwelt hauster der kann php und mai sql
deswegen ist es nicht verkehrt man ein bisschen php kann
ja laravel ist tatsächlich nice ich ach ja übrigens wenn wir von back end
reden vielleicht mache ich den frontend weil von back end java script warum sind
wir sind übrigens noch
wir sind ja immer noch beim back end da würde ich sagen java script back end
was nord js angeht vielleicht sollte man es doch nicht in frontend back end
teilen ich mache nichts mit nord js ganz ehrlich ich habe keine ahnung von
nord js ich kenne die nord js standard library nicht und nix ich kann java
script ja aber ich habe von nord js kein plan mach ich mach back end nord js
immer einen bogen drum ich meine ich krieg damit was gebacken wenn ich damit
was basteln muss aber
kein plan also ich verstehe auch ehrlich gesagt nicht warum ich nord js im
back end verwenden sollte es sei denn also die der einzige grund der mir
einfallen würde es gibt es okay es gibt zwei gründe die mir einfallen würden
warum man nord im back end verwenden sollte das ist einmal weil man krasser
frontend java script checker ist und eben im back end java script verwenden will
man ist das einzige ist was man kann oder weil es irgendwelche super geilen npm
packages gibt die ich verwenden will ansonsten hat irgendjemand jetzt mal
ernsthaft hat sonst noch irgendjemand eine sinnvolle begründung für java
script im back end ok leuchtet ein ja verstehe ich wobei ich das mit
puppeteer.net mache puppeteer sharp heißt glaube ich ob es auch ein binding easy
aufzusetzen gut sind andere sachen auch gleiche codebase ja ok
das ist ja schon alt aber trifft immer wieder gut ist aber halt die realität
ja das sage ich ja wenn man sich auskennt im frontend aber ansonsten ja
dann machen wir noch generell mal hier dort das müssen wir anders nennen das
muss ich irgendwie platt platforms oder sowas keine ahnung wie nennt man das
runtimes mit dort nett kenne ich mich auch ziemlich gut aus an sich also ich
könnte theoretisch auf wichelt basic.net programmieren aber ich will
kein wichelt basic.net programmieren
f sharp habe ich noch nie was gemacht mit außer mal in hello world oder so der
frame frameworks der frameworks trifft sie eigentlich nicht ja machen wir mal
weiter ok was für was für programmier sprachen krieg ich sonst noch krieg ich
sonst noch zusammen ok ich weiß was wir brauchen
oder best best zählt besser als eigene sprache gar ist es ja im prinzip best
kann ich nicht schlecht sie hast du sicher auch schon benutzt ja das würde
ich mal hier mit rein zählen wobei ich halt sagen würde z ist an sich eine
super geschichte aber z plus plus ist kacke
assembler naja also ich kann eine schleife in assembler machen was
wahrscheinlich auch wieder mehr ist als 99,999 prozent der weltbevölkerung können
aber wirklich gut nicht
was empfiehlst du denn fürs back end was willst du denn machen
battle schieb dann kann ich dir auch was sagen
awk ist auch nur sprachig aber das awk und seht und sonst fast zähle ich da
jetzt nicht auf perl allah
was oft exes immer schlimmer also wenn du mir sagst dass du machen willst kann
ich dir aus einfaches kleines webprojekt mit datenbank dahinter
sq light oder richtig echte datenbank ich persönlich bin ja sq light fern für
kleinen kram ja also ich würde hiermit machen ich
würde sp.net verwenden sp.net core bitte schön ich sp.net sp.net ist sachen aus der
steinzeit ich ich verwende gerne sp.net core allerdings ganz ehrlich wenn ich
nicht schon sich habe könnte ich würde wahrscheinlich das da nehmen also wenn ich
wirklich das minimalste am minimalsten brauche im back end dann würde ich das
hier nehmen example
hallo example das sind nur drei zeilen example soll ich mich veräppeln ja das
alles was du machen musst oder kriegst du wenn du die wenn du die
seite aufruf steht dann hello world drauf also das finde ich nice also wenn ich
was ganz ganz kleines minimales brauchen würde und nicht so ein großer c sharp
fanboy wäre das ist quasi ein bisschen wie senatra für ruby genau dann würde
ich das verwenden was ist genau back end und was frontend das ist einfach zu
beantworten frontend ist alles was bei dir auf dem rechner im browser läuft
back end ist alles was auf dem server läuft das kann man das ist tatsächlich
mal eine sache die kann man relativ einfach trennen und klassifizieren
normalerweise ist die antwort immer so grau so ja aber es gibt auch so was und
es gibt was in der mitte da gibt es eigentlich nichts in der mitte frontend
ist alles was bei dir auf dem rechner im browser läuft und back end ist alles
was auf dem server läuft fertig das kann man in dem fall tatsächlich mal ganz
gut trennen was ist mit plays a server side rendering das ist server side und
sobald sie auf dem klein sind die seiten und dort irgendwas dynamisch läuft dann
ist es frontend da ist es kleinzeit das kann man schon relativ einfach trennen
also alles interaktive alles interaktive ist klein seit ich ja und selbst wenn es
über irgendwelche signal a geschichten geht letztendlich wird die webseite im
klein gerendert
es gibt ja so was in der richtung schon du kannst ja beispielsweise dort net
komplett in web assembly laufen lassen dann kannst du theoretisch auch dein
backends im frontend machen aber dann ist es halt kein backend mehr sondern
es ist ein teil von einem frontend
ja razor pages ist auch server side rendering und dann auf dem klein und
sobald du da was interaktives macht mit javascript oder sonst wie dann ist es
wieder frontend also ich finde das kann man schon relativ klar trennen so was
macht man wenn man übermüdet ist schlafen würde ich sagen also wenn man
übermüdet ist eine steckdose aufmachen ist glaube ich nicht so eine gute idee
gibt es mittelend nee so was gibt es nicht es gibt es gibt so was wie
mittelware was man ab und zu verwendet wird als teile von irgendeiner server
pipeline oder sowas das ist aber auch backends so also weiter was für
programmiersprachen habe ich jetzt noch was habe ich jetzt noch vergessen
da man besch so irgendwas vergessen kann ich sonst noch irgendwas haben
irgendwas im stream gemacht javascript bap go java c++ bei schruby c sharp
wird heute noch was geprogrammt wahrscheinlich nicht programming
languages wir gucken einfach mal ob ich da irgendwas ganz offensichtlich ist
übersehen habe wo ich jetzt einfach nicht dran denke ok pausen ja was gibt
es die scharpe ccgo r nein habe ich kein swift habe ich auch kein plan von
ach groovy du hast recht groovy kann ich tatsächlich das ist das einzige was ich
jemals an projekt ab oder sagen wir mal in anfangen abgeschlossen habe auf der
jvm groovy tatsächlich ja habe ich habe ich tatsächlich mal gemacht
javascript bap css typescript ruby c swift habe ich kein plan von
objective c und er habe ich auch kein plan von schell hatte ich skala kein plan
von go power shell ich habe eine sache bisher die letzten jahre über mal in
power shell gemacht aber das würde ich nicht sagen als hellig großen plan von
power shell und perl habe ich auch keine großartung ja gut flatter ist eher so
was wie richtung dart frameworks noch dabei kommt es war auch noch easy
flatter da es zehn prozent vielleicht ich habe schon mal ein beispielprojekt
gemacht sql soll ich sql dabei schreiben ja das problem bei sql ist sql bin ich
schlecht also sql also sql queries schreiben habe ich keinen plan wieso ich
das mache weil ich mal vor über einem jahr meinem chef gesagt habe ich will ein
bisschen mehr programmierstelle machen hat gesagt ja müssen wir ein bisschen
rumgucken da habe ich zu ihm gesagt ja ich schicke dir einfach mal eine
übersichtseite mit sachen die ich gut kann und das habe ich mich jetzt über
ein jahr wieder verdrängt das ganze ich habe mir gedacht jetzt mache ich das
einfach mal soft skills oh ja dass das muss sein
soft skills ok scrum
ops scrum eitel kann bahn ein moment das muss man linkser ich schreibe jetzt
einfach einfach irgendwas rein
ajay lean die schäbte schäbte teams
das aber noch sonst so schön ist test driven development clean code
block chain a block chain sind keine soft skills iot iot muss auch noch irgendwo
rein ich weiß ich weiß bloß noch nicht wo er weiß
bloß noch nicht wo voll voll das ist aber auch kein soft skill full stack ja
ok man wollte es jetzt nicht übertreiben die hälfte davon habe ich habe ich
eigentlich auch kein plan aber das witzige ist dass eigentlich keiner so
wirklich plan davon hatten einfach so tut als ob
ok wunderbar wunderbar
team fähig konstruktiv innovationsfreudig also zusammengefasst
5 hat
ist ihr was das schlimme ist das fällt überhaupt nicht auf zwischen diesen
dämlichen buzz words dass da 5 hat steht das sieht so aus als gehört es da
einfach rein
jammel jammel schreibe noch ein genau aber jammel
ja doch er kommt bei der bei def ob skills da kann ich kann aber tippen
jason jason jason von 100 prozent ich kann sogar jammel variablen und so
easy
xml 9 xml schreibe ich da erst gar nicht rein reicht mir schon das microsoft
zu sehr auf xml steht frontend frameworks oh ja ja ja dass das vielleicht auch
nicht schlecht ok frontend frameworks ich kann eigentlich nur vgs kann ich
was kann ich denn sonst noch doch das stimmte ich kann kraft ql
kann ich denn da kann ich kann ich überhaupt irgendwas
die react kann ich nicht habe ich noch nie verwendet bin ich der große frontend
lara lara im beck ja das kann man
ich weiß übrigens gar nicht wie man schreibt mit l oder mit l stopp mit einem
l angular ne angular schreibe ich da nicht rein da muss ich ja noch was in
angular machen die 100 prozent lull keg weight ich habe das vor fünf jahren mal
verwendet für irgendwie eine kleine seite lull man muss prinzipiell gar
nichts auf haben ich schreibe gerade einfach alles auf ich werde es auch nicht
eins zu eins meinem chef so schicken oder so
was was habe ich noch für ahnung ich meine vba
pains chat bloß nicht kein vba hört mir auf
euer tailwind kann ich jetzt ein bisschen haben wir letztens geübt
ich wollte noch schnell habe ich irgendwelche programmier sprachen
vergessen nein sieht nicht so aus alles klar exzellent ja das wusste ich alles
auflisten so ich gerade programmier sprachen sind schon mal nicht verkehrt
bootstrap ruby haben wir drin hier guck ruby
ich werde es auch nicht so abgeben ich schreibe einfach alles ich schreibe jetzt
einfach alles drauf jetzt machen wir mal jetzt kommen massif der fob skills
brauchen wir jetzt huge also erst mal erst mal shit
puppet habe ich ganz gut ansible kann ich mittlerweile ganz gut jenkins kann ich
ganz gut github actions kann ich ganz gut github an sich kann ich wunderbar
verwende jeder mittlerweile shit und shit hab
was fast verum moment defops roadmap wir lassen uns jetzt einfach mal
inspirieren der fob roadmap also das schreibe ich da doch nicht drauf ich
schreibe da noch nicht screen und die markt drauf dachte kommt man kommt man
kommt sich der leser verarscht vor
man best scripting wim wim wim ich weiß nicht wo das hinkommt das muss hier unter
linux oder genau wim excellent wim skills
ja diesen ganzen krempel hier könnte ich da auch noch hinschreiben also ich
habe ich habe ahnung von nginx ich habe ahnung wir machen mal laut balancer in
einem trafik weiß nicht wie man den kram schreibt irgendwie so
habe ich richtig geschrieben hätte ich gar nicht gedacht
apache ist pains gempt das schreibe ich nicht drauf aber kennst du das ganz gut
mit mit aus habe ich das falsch geschrieben oder
ach doch habe ich falsch geschrieben das sind aussicht zu zungenbrecher immer
ja das nicht verkehrt hinzuschreiben so konsul ist das in irgendwelche key
value store gedöns es da bin ich ja der der richtiges skiller im es also
windows windows webserver cloud fehlen cloud hatten wir hier cloud aber da
da fehlen die die da fehlt noch einiges ja
es ist ja der forst habe ich keinen plan von ich kenne mich eigentlich nur ganz
gut mit jenkins und github actions aus ja vm wir virtualisierungs kram vielleicht
noch
virtualisierung da habe ich aber eigentlich gar keinen plan von da habe
ich echt keinen plan von ich meine ich kann vm installieren aber ich habe keine
ahnung von von irgendwie esx administration oder so was das kann ich
da auch nicht reinschreiben weil wenn es eine sache gibt mit der sich mal chef
auskennt ist es ex-administration da hatte echt ahnung von das hat er früher
gemacht da weiß er bescheid da weiß er echt bescheid er kennt kann in den raffer
reinschreiben einfach joko groups erwähnen ja kann ich dann auch noch
schreibt er ich habe dann auch die docker stellz brauche man natürlich auch
noch hier natürlich natürlich natürlich sack sack natürlich das muss
ja auch noch alles bei der fob skills reiner docker docker kompose
wird es eine liste fürs arbeitszeug ist weder noch ich schreibe ich ich ich habe
mir jetzt über ich schreibe erst mal alles auf was ich irgendwie kann und dann
gucke ich mal nach was man damit dann anfängt so was haben die hier noch
schönes trinchen ihrer defops liste sonst nichts oder alibaba cloud die
chinesen cloud wollen wir uns mal einen test warum warum warum warum ist die
warum ist die alibaba cloud warum gibt es da eigentlich kein häkchen dran
was ist das wieder für rassistischer höchst rassistische liste die chinesen
werden ausgegrenzt leute china chinesen cloud wird nicht verwendet ich meine es
könnte vielleicht was damit zu tun haben dass das datenschutz technisch
bedenklich ist aber nein kann ich sein die china cloud so alibaba cloud wie kann
man sich da anmelden zu
zehn zwölf monate free trial ja per ich will jetzt die alibaba cloud
haben das sind doch stock images das ist doch gar nix für die
ops jetzt hätte ich fast leute beinahe beinahe hätte ich blok ausgemacht
warum hätte ich warum will ich den blok ausmachen ausgerechnet auf der
chinesen cloud so kann man sich da free account ich war mir jetzt einfach ein
fake account alle fake account account so so germany your mail ja ja alles klar
ok 10 minute mail brauchen wir jetzt wir brauchen hier so ein fake das da
register enter your passport das sage ich euch nicht das password
das password muss ich mir auch mal kurz aufschreiben
ok passt perfekt
ok confirm save was
ja ok notification vor wo ist die
bei faun nein nicht bei faun bei faun oder kennst du an unbox net nee habe ich
noch nicht ausprobiert ist das deine webseite und du machst promotion oder ist
es wie sagt bloß die haben das geplogged
achso ich muss send noch erst klicken ich kacke kacke noob kostenlosen faun
von alibar das probieren wir jetzt aus probiert aus aliexpress cloud china
chinesen cloud alter kommt nicht an
so wie wie wie machen wir das jetzt
dies bestimmt ist bestimmt blacklisted ist alle ex auf hier
big bang obhigh rose firefight
success voll der崴 individual account fast nämn peter akile
agilé french e adresse ja zeil eins bangfurt am ein hessen
geht nicht ich muss mal kurz den dark reader aus machen leute hessen nein oder faun
und 1 5 1 die woher wollen die woher wollen die wissen dass es nicht eine
valid nummer ist ohne null fuck identity verification was ist was ist mit den
chinesen los warum interessiert die das überhaupt buber okay was ist wenn ich
jetzt enterprise mach da brauche ich auch verification id shit den voter von
kund blue, okay okay sab mit was
Mist wie kriege ich jetzt ein Fake Telefon noch mal her?
Scheiße Was ist das free online phone ja perfekt
Free online phone sehr gut sehr gut
4.9 gibt es keinen gibt es kein German
Tinder Accounts Alter
Ach man muss jetzt bloß 4.9 nehmen
Ach scheiße man oh nee jetzt habe ich das zu gemacht
Oh knapp Stimmt landender
Nee land kann man ja auch nicht
Ok dann scheiße das funktioniert nicht
Ok
Was temp sms.net kann man das aufmachen?
Temp sms.net ok ich hoffe das gibt es jetzt keine Pornwerbung drauf oder so
German
Chinese Nummer
Wo sind die German Numbers Leute?
Wo sind die German Temporary Numbers Germany?
Ok
Alles klar Bäm das brauchen wir jetzt
Das ist wahrscheinlich schon belegt send
Ok
So und jetzt ist die Frage
Was machen die denn da rufen die da jetzt an oder schicken die da
Als ob da jemand sein Amazon Account ja doch da hat jemand sein Amazon Account drauf registriert
Sag mal die machen online Banking da drüber
Die machen ernsthaft online Banking da drüber
Die Leute
Scheiße ok das funktioniert glaube ich nicht
Appeal oh nee
Wie kriege ich mich da registriert Reobtain
Nee das funktioniert nicht
Ok das tut nicht Temp SMS wo hat Temp SMS haben die irgendwie Germany
Das Problem ist wahrscheinlich hat sich schon längst jemand mit dieser Nummer bei Aliexpress
registriert
Handy Nummer ich gebe doch da jetzt keine gültige Handy Nummer ein
Receive SMS Punkt kommen ok easy machen wir jetzt
Noch hier zu outen ok perfekt
Whatsapp Alter was da alles für Zeug drin liegt
Jalla online Casino
Von Susi196601 alles klar
Auch Chinesen macht hinne ey
China Chinesen Mensch
Ich nehme keine Nummern von euch hallo
Nein entweder das geht hier mit oder es
Mensch warum geht das nicht
V-SIM-Card
Die haben es erkannt dass ich Fake Accounts machen will
Ok wir probieren jetzt noch was aus
Ok hier tut es nichts ok dann probieren wir den jetzt noch aus
Fake Nummer ok next Aliexpress
Zack
So wenn das jetzt nicht geht haben wir gelitten
Aber auf alle Captain Peng Dankeschön für die Zaps
Jaja
Ich glaube Tank-Code
Was
Ich glaube die haben mich geblockt
Oh nee keine Ads please
Ich bin geblockt ok
Ok kein Aliexpress Account Leute
Kein Chinesen Account
Enterprise Account Lul
Fuck
Ok keine Chance
Keine Chance keine China Chinesen
Das ist was anderes oder
Das ist das ist doch was anderes
V123456 ok Leute keine Chance
Vorbei
Grip Aliexpress Alter
Wie im Moment
Warum geht denn das jetzt auf einmal
Wait a minute
Warum geht denn das jetzt doch
Muss ich das gar nicht machen
When she baited
G-Trial
Elastic Compute Service
Ok try now
Ah she baited
Ok geht doch nicht
Wie würde ich denn hier jetzt überhaupt was anlegen in der China Cloud
Server Load Balancer Cloud Monitor Elastic Compute Service
Wie würde ich hier mal eine billige VM anlegen in der China Chinesen Cloud
Sag mal der geht mir gerade echt auf den Kekse Dark Reader
Instances Images
VPC?
Nee
Disks
Create Disk
Ja ja ich und ich
Ah Mist
Ok die checken das echt
Ok Leute keine Chance
Keine Chance man kann
Main Business
Wie
Vielleicht kann man das irgendwie austricksen
Frankfurt am Main
Teil 1
Ah Mist
Fax
Plus 49
Warum kann ich das nicht safen
Ah Business Name
Ah das ging jetzt oder was
Ich bin voll überfordert
Private Virtual Cloud
Wie macht man bei den Chinesen
Irgendeinen Server
Das ist ja noch unübersichtlicher als AWS
Ok Cloud Shell Cloud Shell ist gut
Cloud Shell Storage Space Create
Ah schau mir da
Moment darf ich jetzt neu
Darf ich jetzt neu
Darf ich jetzt neu Handy nochmal gibbeten
Ok die haben mich geploggt keine Chance
Oh nee ich hab Angst bei was da für ein Ad kommt
Ok Leute nope keine Chance
Keine China Chinesen Cloud
Private Window
Keine Chance Bam
China geht nicht
So und was wir jetzt noch machen ist
One more
Moment Moment
Wo löscht man den Kram jetzt nochmal
Preferences History Clear
Äh letzte Stunde Bam
Ganzer China Kram wieder weg
Ok aber ich würde sagen wir kennen uns jetzt damit schon mal relativ gut aus
Also können wir sagen Alibaba Cloud auf jeden Fall schon mal eins ja
Also für irgendwas muss ich das jetzt ja gelohnt haben
Ich hab jetzt zumindest schon mal die Cloud Konsole gesehen von Alibaba
So ok wo sind wir stehen geblieben
Wo sind wir denn davor stehen geblieben
Der Forbes Kram sind wir stehen geblieben
Wieso Hetzner weil ich mich damit ganz gut auskenne
Das da
Das bin ich
Woher willst du wissen dass ich in Wirklichkeit Max heiß
Also gar nicht wieder drauf kommt
Datenbanken na Datenbanken muss ich ehrlich gesagt nichts machen da hört es bei mir direkt
auf nach Abinstall Postgres
Mehr ASP.NET Core ach stimmt das müssen wir natürlich reinschreiben ja genau
Da bin ich nicht schlecht drinne
So ok Programmiersprachen haben wir alles würde ich sagen
So Defob Stels Ansible Jenkins und so was Terraform kenne ich mich auch ein bisschen mit aus
Ja gut GitLab ja
Das ärgert mich jetzt dass ich die China Cloud nicht nicht angelegt bekommen habe
Ja das juckt aber kein ehrlich gesagt
Kommen wir machen jetzt einfach noch hier Ede Editor kann ich ein bisschen mit Wim skills
Wim skills flexen
Jetbrains Zeug kenne ich mich auch gut aus
VS Code kenne ich mich auch gut aus
Ja was soll ich da sonst reinschreiben
Ach so ja Soft Skills da müssen wir natürlich noch so Sachen wie Jyra und Confluence und
so im Gedönsranche
Wobei das ja eigentlich keine Soft Skills sind das sind ja
Tools oder so
Wie macht man die Preview du sagst dir einfach Open Markdown Open Preview Markdown to the
side und dann hast du es hier
So was gibt es jetzt mal ernsthaft was ist denn noch interessant also was muss man da
noch reinschreiben
Es gibt so viele Sachen wo ich mir noch nie Gedanken zu gemacht habe und wahrscheinlich
ich auch schon gemacht habe aber mir nie drüber nachgedacht habe
Exis Soft Skills ich hasse Menschen
Keck Wait Achja Netzwerk Netzwerk ist vielleicht nicht schlecht
Wobei ich Netzwerk ich hab mal ein CCNA gemacht 0w 2007
Ich glaube nicht dass es irgendwas noch irgendwie raus reißt
CCNA von 2007 ist glaube ich Who Cares
Nee ich glaube ich gar nicht von 2007 ist sogar glaube ich von 2008 oder 9 oder so
Das habe ich schon hingeschrieben bei Linux bei Linux Skills
Gibst du das deinem Chef 1 zu 1 nein Quatsch Wobei warum eigentlich nicht
Kommunikation tja kommt drauf an ob ich die Leute mag oder nicht
Lohnt sich CCNA eigentlich schwer zu sagen also für mich hat es sich bis jetzt nicht
gelohnt
Ja was kann ich denn im Netzwerk bereich ich kann Open Sense PF Sense ein bisschen
Wobei es gar nicht Open Sense heißt sondern Open Open Open Sense heißt ja
Warum auch immer man das nicht Open Sense sondern Open Open Sense genannt hat
Mikrotik Unify Ohbei
Die kann ich immer nicht schreiben das ist zwar jetzt kein Business Zeug aber es schadet
sicherlich auch nichts wenn man das mal reinschreibt
Kann ich sonst noch irgendwie Netzwerk mäßig großartig was
Doch kann ich Fritzbox
Ich glaube das ist ganz furchtbar entscheidend dass ich in Fritzbox reinschreibe
Du hast nicht mitbekommen warum ich das mache weil
Moment wo war dann hier die Frage Weil ich mal irgendwann vor über einem Jahr
meinem Chef gesagt habe ich würde gern ein bisschen mehr Sachen programmieren auf der
Arbeit
Ich habe jetzt ein Jahr lang ignoriert und ich habe mir gedacht ich mache das jetzt einfach
mal
Leute mir gehen langsam die IOT brauchen wir noch IOT IOT Moment
IOT ist so bescheuert brauche ich auf der Arbeit nie im Leben
Aber was soll ich da was soll ich da reinschreiben
Ich habe ein bisschen Ahnung von Embedded Kram
Wobei der Patrick ist doch noch da oder Patrick bist du noch da geht mein ESP32 und ESP266
Zeug was ich da mache als Embedded durch
Oder sagt da sagt da jeder
Distribute Cluster ja das stimmt stimmt stimmt ja ja ja hast du recht
Also ich erkenne mich mit HA aus Cluster Kram
Schreibt mir jetzt einfach mal was auf ich weiß nicht wie ich es nenne
IBM Mainframe Liner habe ich keine Ahnung von
Was machst du denn auf der Arbeit ich mache das hier guck mal
Ich habe da sogar ein extra Video zu gemacht
Ich habe schon fast alle schon mal ein Video gemacht
Social Media Skills Twitter Flamer Twitch Twitch Emote Expert
Ich weiß gar nicht wo ich den ganzen Kram hier noch dazu reinschreiben soll
Borderlands ist schon wieder so alt ja
Boah Leute mein Brain macht nicht mehr mit
Ich kann mir mal nachdenken gerade MonkaS
Da gibt es nur noch 100.000 Sachen und Gott und die Welt was ich da reinschreiben kann
Ich bestelle mir jetzt erstmal bei Amazon schnell noch was
Und zwar noch 16x16 LED Matrix fällt mir gerade so ein brauche ich
Virtualisierung habe ich schon aber da kenne ich mich nicht wirklich gut mit aus
Oh ich kann ein paar VMs aufsetzen aber von ESX Administration habe ich keine Ahnung
Wie warum ist denn das so teuer geworden
Warum ist das so teuer geworden ich habe da 15 Euro für bezahlt
Keckweight Inflation Kick auch bei LED
Stellhand beim China Chinesen ja das mache ich jetzt auch
AliExpress 16x16 LED
Weil ich will noch ich will noch zwei Lampen davon drucken
Guck ich habe mir doch von ich habe mir doch hier so eine Lampe 3D gedruckt und die ist
wirklich nice also das ist das erste mal wo ich es wirklich gesagt habe da ist was
brauchbares cooles bei rausgekommen beim 3D drucken
Hier die da mit WLED die Lampe ist wirklich nice geworden
Da wollte ich mir noch zwei drei von machen LED Lampen kann man nie genug haben
Und dazu brauche ich halt so ein 16x16 LED Matrix
Die ist halt echt nice geworden guck so sah sie auf dem 3D Drucker aus
Mein Druckbett hat auch schon bessere Zeiten gesehen
Leute ich habe letztens den meinen mega geilen 3D Drucker gesehen auf YouTube
Das ist 3D Drucker CNC Fräse und Laser Gravur Gerät in einem
Ich will euch hier nochmal kurz zeigen Kaufe ich mir nicht
Weil das Ding kann Laser Gravieren 3D Drucken und CNC Fräsen
Richtig richtig abgedrehtes Teil kostet aber kostet aber 2000 Euro oder so
Nee nee geht glaube ich ab 1200 Euro los geht ab 1200 Euro los und
Aber für die Größe bezahlst du dann 2000 Euro Das ist gar nicht mal so teuer ne
Das ist gar nicht mal so teuer aber es ist halt insgesamt 250 Euro 3D Drucker relativ
teuer Das macht auch einen hochwertigen Eindruck
mit dem Ding zum bedienen Du hast den Laser der kann auch automatisch
kalibrieren und alles Guck hier Gravurstelz das ist das Video
Ihr Gravurstelz kannst du machen Du kannst natürlich 3D Drucken das ist
klar Die übliche 3D Druckgeschichte
Dann kannst du hier Gravurstelz machen Und dann kann das Ding auch CNC Fräsen
Ich mein man braucht es nicht aber es ist schon irgendwie ein geiles Gerät
Oder müsst ihr zugeben Ist schon wirklich nice
Nee nee nicht Laser ohne Gehäuse Du kriegst ein Gehäuse drum herum
Du kriegst ein Gehäuse mit was auch für Laser schützt und so
Der hat es nur für die Aufnahmen weggelassen Das ist richtig cool
Aber brauche ich nicht Ich fand es nur geil
Ich fand es nur geil So was kostet es bei den China Chinesen
Guck bei den China Chinesen kostet es das gleiche Panel
Einfach mal nur 10 Euro anstatt 25 in Deutschland Das ist genau das gleiche Panel
Ach das ist 8 mal 8 ich brauch 16 mal 16 Nächste Woche Video dazu
Nein WTF ich kauf mir das nicht
Es ist nur geil Aber ich geb doch im Leben
Ich geb doch im Leben da 2000 Euro für ein Gerät was ich nie verwende
Wobei So unwahrscheinlich ist es nicht
Aber nein mach ich es nicht In dem Fall mach ich es nicht
Nein nein nein mach ich es nicht Ja hätten mal die die von diesem Videoschnittprogramm
die bei mir Werbung machen wollten mein Angebot akzeptiert
Dann hätte ich jetzt ein bisschen mehr Geld gehabt und hätte mir das kaufen können
Und ich könnte mir das auch so kaufen aber ich sehe es nicht ein ich muss mich ein bisschen
zurückhalten Ich gebe ja eh schon nicht viel Geld aus
Aber ich habe manchmal den Hang dazu so Spielkrams zu kaufen von dem ich genau weiß ich brauche
ihn eigentlich nicht Irgendwas in Richtung Middleware Integration
Message Mappings Du meinst irgendwelche Message Que Geschichten
so von Rabbit MQ bis sonst was von Spring habe ich keine Ahnung
Ja Byte Strike genau Woher weißt du das
Die machen gerade überall Werbung
Die haben ich gefragt und ich habe gesagt Ja können wir machen Placement 800 Euro haben
die gemeint 800 Euro ist uns zu viel Wobei ich das voll und ganz angemessen
finde ehrlich gesagt Für das was die wollten
Und ich habe mir jetzt überlegt ob ich jetzt nicht einfach noch mal noch mal sagen soll
ja ok Machen wir 500 Euro und es gibt noch einen
Twitter Post dabei oder so Aber drunter mache ich das nicht
Die wollten links also also Donald links und sonst was und die wollten 60 plus als 60
Sekunden Plus Placement mitten in einem Video haben
Und das mache ich nicht für ein Apfel und ein Ei
60 Sekunden Video Placement das kannst du nicht überspringen das ist reingerendert
das nimmt das ganze total aus dem Video Fluss raus die Leute haben kein Bock schalten ab
also das muss schon ordentlich bezahlt werden dass ich das mache
Da ist 800 Euro aber schon frech was für 60 Sekunden Werbung ist da
Weißt du was du woanders bezahlst für 60 Sekunden Werbung
Du mal ich ja auch noch 60 Sekunden Werbung also die Werbung soll ich ja auch noch machen
also sprich ich soll War das MonkaS alter
Ah paar Schrauben waren das die Schrauben Päckchen die runtergefallen sind
Lull Ach du meinst vielleicht billig ja ja
Ja die Werbung soll ich ja auch noch machen also sprich ich krieg dann vielleicht einen
Clip oder so von denen und soll dann da 60 Sekunden auch noch drüber labern
aber ich habe gleich schon gesagt also irgendwie persönliche Empfehlungen kann ich nicht geben
weil ich benutze das ja nicht ja ach nee ach nee nee nee
also für 500 Euro würde ich dann vielleicht gerade so aber auch nicht komplett was sie
sich vorgestellt haben machen aber sonst würde ich nicht bringt ja nix bringt ja nix
wenn man das alles umsonst macht Was willst du für eine Minute Bitbattle
Gameplay gar nix
Raid Shadow Legends Gameplay ja da krieg ich das doppelte für allerdings das Problem
bei Raid Shadow Legends Gameplay ist oder bei bei Raid Shadow Legends ist das haben
die ja auch schon gleich am Anfang geschrieben du musst halt so tun als findest du's geil
also alle anderen sind damit zufrieden wenn man sagt was weiß ich das ist hier Produkt
XY das ist das das ist das beste für das und das zu machen und so das ist okay aber
Raid Shadow Legends will dass du quasi sagst ich spiele dieses Spiel schon ein halbes Jahr
und das hat mich selten ein RPG so begeistert ladet euch jetzt Raid Shadow Legends runter
die die legen da die legen da wirklich wirklich wer drauf und ne mach ich nicht mach ich nicht
vergiss es echt ist das Pains Champ hab ich noch nie verwendet ich hab's auch nicht vor
zu verwenden um ehrlich ehrlich zu sein Cloud oder Hardware Shop Corporation mach mal ausrufe
Zeichen Hetzner ich bin grad dabei ich hab mir denen schon ein Testvideo gemacht bei
Hetzner und ich bin gerade dabei denen ein Vorschlag zu schicken für so komplettes
monatliches so ein Paket mit monatliche mit monatlicher Zahlung ja da werde ich dann so
Sachen rein machen wie Stream Overlay und dass es commands gibt im Chat man könnte beispielsweise
auch Discord messages rein machen Videobeschreibung alle möglichen Sachen ich bin da grad dabei
sowas zusammenzuschreiben wo ich ich werde es wahrscheinlich so machen ich schlag den
drei Sachen vor mit drei drei unterschiedlichen unterschiedlichen Preisen ja keine Ahnung
500 Euro 1000 Euro 1500 ich weiß es noch nicht keine Ahnung und dann ist dann halt
je nachdem wie umfangreich die Sache ist können sie sich dann raussuchen was sie haben wollen
was ich nie wieder machen werde ist so ne so ne G2A Geschichte mit festen Videoanzahlen
im Monat das mach ich nie wieder das fand ich kacke aber G2A war auch merkwürdig denen
waren Aufrufe egal die wollten nur viele Videos haben also die waren ganz merkwürdig so im
nachhinein betrachtet die waren ganz die waren ganz merkwürdig ne ich hab ja auch versucht
zu erklären so nach dem Motto hey wenn ich weniger Videos mache das ist sogar besser
weil unterm Strich eure Videos sogar noch mehr geguckt werden ich hatte die ja nicht in jedem
Video drinne aber ich hab gesagt guck mal diese Videos wo ihr drinne seid also bei G2A
die gucken dann sogar mehr wenn ich Videos mache sonst war der egal die wollten Videos
haben in massen die waren die waren komisch IprepperRS ach ne IpepperRS nicht wird nicht
gepreppt Dankeschön für den Sub Abofaller hat auch Subscribed Dankeschön vor 26 Minuten
Prime Sub der Captain Peng auch schon sieben Monate huge Subscriptions Leute Dankeschön
für die ganzen Subs Klopapierprepper ich wurde total geflamed dafür dass ich Klopapier
damals könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern als ich mal auf Twitter gepostet hab ich hab
mir ne Palette war ja nicht wirklich ne komplette Palette aber ich sag jetzt einfach mal in
der Richtung ich hab mir ne Palette Klopapier bestellt wie sie sich aufgeregt haben auf
Twitter alle wieder Max du bist Teil des Problems und deswegen wegen dir kann ich mir mein
Bob es nicht abputzen und sowas meine Güte haben dich aufgeregt Alter dabei hab ich das
ja nicht irgendwie beim Rewe bestellt sondern in nem Großhandel und die hatten jederzeit
genug und die haben explizit gesagt sie beliefern wenn es Engpässe gibt auch zuerst Krankenhäuser
und alles das heißt was ich bekommen hab an Klopapier damals war vollkommen quasi ohne
Einfluss auf die anderen Leute außer dass ich genug Klopapier hatte und die anderen
die sich permanent eingeredet haben dass sie irgendwie moralisch überlegen sind weil sie
sich jetzt den Bobes mit einem Stück zweimal abputzen nicht aber tja so sind sie halt
die Twitter Flamer ja Video Einblendung mit FFmpeg da viel mehr sollte man damit aber
auch nicht machen also das geht man kann ja Offerlays machen mit FFmpeg aber schön ist
was anderes Leute ich bin zu Lowbrain ich krieg ich krieg gerade nicht mehr nicht mehr
Skillers zusammen irgendwie das ist zu mein Hirn setzt mein Hirn setzt aus grad vorbei
Running Low on Cuties ja so siehts aus wo sind sie denn alle hin wo ist wo ist der Chat
investierst du eigentlich an der Börse nein ich mach aktuell in der Richtung gar nichts
aber ich sollte das unbedingt machen weil ich hab achso ja ich kann euch ja noch was
erzählen aber vorher beantworten ich das ne mach ich nicht ich hab heute war ich aber
wieder geschockt als ich auf mein Konto geguckt hab ich hab Geld vom Automat abgeholt da liegt
viel zu viel Geld rum und auf dem Business Konto liegt auch viel zu viel Geld rum ich
muss unbedingt den Kram irgendwie investieren und sei es nur in langfristig einfach was
nehmen für zum Beispiel genau irgendwas wie ETFs oder so aber das Problem ist ich hab
von sowas keine Ahnung ich beschäftige mich auch einfach nur ungern damit auch ich weiß
dass das blöd ist aber ich muss das unbedingt machen weil ansonsten ist es nur noch die
Hälfte wert frag her Endpunkt ich glaub da hat davon auch nicht so viel Ahnung Bitcoin
ist aktuell gut zu investieren es ist runter gibt es überhaupt noch Sparbücher ja gut
geben tut es das noch das macht dann die Oma von der Oma so das ist ja auch schon vorbei
wie jetzt soll ich MrBeast Style machen der nächste der meinen Tweet retweetet ich verlose
unter allen die retweeten 100.000 Euro ne 10.000 Dollar macht er ja immer MrBeast Style
ja ja ganz bestimmt ich mein damit kann man sie übelst krass natürlich Follower Sachen
auch holen wer diesen Tweet retweetet und Follower unter allen die retweet und Follower
verlose ich 5000 Euro und dann ist natürlich die Frage überprüft überhaupt irgendjemand
ob er das macht gut der hat genug Geld der wird es wahrscheinlich machen aber es gibt
bestimmt genug Leute die faken sowas war nicht war nicht mal hat gab es da nicht mal
bei Simon Desue so ein Miniskandal damals der auch gesagt hat hier ihr bekommt Geld
und dann hat er das nie bezahlt und hat die Leute gescampt aber gut bei Simon Desue wundert
mich ja nichts mehr und ApoRed okay das weiß ich nicht mehr bei ApoRed weiß ich nur noch
dass der mal einen Bombenprank kennt ihr noch den Bombenprank von ApoRed das war so blöd
da hätte man sich doch auch da wäre man doch auch auf die Idee gekommen im Vorfeld schon
dass es vielleicht nicht so sinnvoll ist das zu machen alter es ist so ah so Paynes Champ
keine zwei Meter gerade ausgedacht den habe ich abonniert auf YouTube ich mach garantiert
nicht all in Bitcoin also den habe ich abonniert auf YouTube den Kerl
ja der ist irgendwie auch weg von der Bildfläche gut ich glaube die die die Stelzen jetzt in
Dubai rum bisschen was an Open Source Projekte spenden ich ich spende ich spende ab und zu
für irgendwelche Tierschutzgeschichten was all in Essen ja das mache ich ja eh schon
ist trotzdem noch was übrig
Leute was machen wenn jetzt wir haben noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit also für für Skill
Stels ist mein mein Hirn ist gerade zu zu low brain ich dafür da kann ich mir nicht
mehr ausdruck aussuchen
Depot eröffnen im Stream näh YouTube Reacts ne hab ich jetzt auch kein Bock drauf
Vingate hat jetzt uninstall upgrade und list das funktioniert doch aber im Leben nicht
richtig das glaube ich dir nicht dass es funktioniert ich moment wohl mein Moment
Video von Geek Freaks waren das die nicht mit dem Windows Tuning Pack
Moment Tag das muss ich mir angucken Ach das ist nicht mein Friseur das ist mein Zahnarzt
meinst du ja genau der spricht wie mein Zahnarzt an installen install ab ok experimental das
muss man sich mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen Microsoft hat einen Package Manager gemacht
wo es experimental ist eine App zu aninstallen
was haben alle mit den Hot Tube Streams es ist ja schon ein bisschen weniger geworden
die üblichen Verdächtigen gibt es immer noch aber so der Riesen der Riesen Aufreger
und Riesen Hype ist ja eigentlich auch schon wieder weg
Paints Champ auf MSI ok immerhin dann wird das vielleicht jetzt mal ernst zu nehmen der
Package Manager demnächst Booba TV gibt's schon ja das kenne ich das
mache ich jetzt aber nicht auf Progress Paradev da musst du glaube ich Serious Max ihr danken
im Chat weil ich glaube der hat es vorhin gepostet da bin ich auch nicht selbst drauf
gekommen
ich gucke noch mal schnell was was sind so die aktuellen GitHub Trends das schaue ich
mir jetzt noch mal schnell an da ist wahrscheinlich nichts großartiges spannendes dabei
Doc was Doc to Shotgun Monka ist was ah das ist ein Crawler das ist ein Bot das ist ein
Bot der einem einen Termin fürs Impfen crapped das ist eigentlich eine coole Idee
das ist doch mal was was ordentliches kippt sich auch für die deutsche ja ich weiß ich
weiß ja Patrick ich weiß ich habe es gelesen im Chat im Discord und das wird das wird
Paints Champ ich ich verstehe nicht warum Microsoft es nicht auf die Reihe klingt
ordentliches UI Framework zu machen China Chinesen Kram versteht man wieder nichts
Deutsch Haus der hat ein Video hochgeladen dass er keinen Bock mehr drauf hat habe ich
heute morgen gesehen okay es gibt mal wieder absolut nichts spannendes was trendet nice
hat sich gelohnt wieso kein chinesen von weil ich selten chinesische zeichen braucht
die leute vermiesen ihm das echt was haben sie gemacht stack overflow hat die fall
von geändert sehr kunde sehr kunde moment moment stack overflow wir suchen jetzt eine
10 plus plus frage auf stack overflow wir müssen ja neue sachen auch gleich mit der
hässlichsten sprache was das gar nicht mal so schlecht muss ich sagen gar nicht mal so
schlecht das ist das ist besser als der alte font was ist das was ist das für ein font
wie nennt man das okay die verwenden einfach kaskas kardia monos die haben einfach nur
die reinfolge geändert was von den lokalen schriftarten verwendet wird oder oder ist das
wirklich aber ich muss sagen das sieht besser aus als vorher kannst du mal erklären was
das alles in der obersten leiste bedeutet als die windows leiste das hier das ist desktop
1 dass ich desktop 2 das ist desktop 3 das ist freier plattenplatz freier ram freier
swap gibt es nicht weil ich habe kein swap freier swap cpu auslastung cpu load lokale
ip und wie viel grad up und down geht übers netzwerk und dann die das aktuelle datum und
netzwerkverbindung ist nicht das ist jetzt kaskadia code wir haben passt ja gut dazu
dass wir gestern neue schriftarten ausprobiert haben ip league monka es
aber ich muss sagen es gefällt mir besser die was hatten die davor courier oder sowas
stack overflow das sah so oldschool aus auf stack overflow die schrift mit welchem programm
kann man gut die temperatur seiner pc hardware überwachen vor frag mich nicht unter windows
keine ahnung ich glaube das ist die neue microsoft schriftart hier die leute hätten richtig
selbst das probieren wir jetzt mal ich finde es eigentlich ganz gut font lesen wir doch
mal wie dazu gibt es keine oder gibt es bestimmt ein hacker news jetzt bestimmt hacker news
eintrag für und und und und reddit und reddit reddit stack overflow gibt es bestimmt auch
was für is it just me or stack overflow incredible toxic ja stack overflow sind sehr viele merkwürdige
leute font font die da wird noch nicht drauf rum geflammt war warum nicht stack warum warum
wird es auch noch nicht drauf rum geflammt die fall font hier we are switching we are
switching fonts das schon das schon ein bisschen okay das ist schon das ist schon ein bisschen
her wo sie das angekündigt haben so da wird da wird garantiert drauf rum geflammt pull
requests würgen wir schon mal nicht
okay was auch immer
ach leute wisst ihr warum es kann das sein dass sie den default font gar nicht geändert
haben ich habe einfach nur total viele fonts installiert ich guck mal leute die haben den
default font doch moment moment moment leute ich habe doch gestern ganz viele ganz viele
font installiert wahrscheinlich ist es deswegen einfach wenn ich den kram wieder habe ich
gestern den snapshot restored wobei kann ich einfach ausprobieren was habe ich gestern
als letzten font installiert ne ist noch alles drauf ah ne okay ich weiß gar nicht was
ich alles installiert habe gestern okay ich muss mal ich muss ich muss ah ne ich kann
nicht rückgängig machen fack da ist ja meine liste weg wenn ich jetzt rückgängig mache
keg weight ja okay was was habe ich da alles installiert man konnte noch mit pack packman
list by install date das geht doch irgendwie wow what the install ich will einfach wissen
listen by install date you can't what the fack font install wunderbar das beste ist einfach
sachen copy pasten wieder ich dachte das geht echt nicht na gut aber was ich machen kann
ist so das ist alles installiert es crept nach minus i ttf nach mein installierten fonts
genau so also das da kann man installieren das da kann man deinstallieren wie mochi braumann
robot und mono kommen installieren meslo kommen deinstallieren jet brands mono kommen
deinstallieren kommen installieren kommen auch deinstallieren vierer kaut kommen auch
Okay, das ist der ganze Kempel von gestern
So und dann, kann man auch deinstallieren, das muss man glaube ich drauf lassen
Wobei, wartet mal, haben wir noch hier, minus minus recursive, dass er alles mit wegschmeißt
So und jetzt, ich mach mal ein Reboot, ich weiß, braucht man nicht, es reicht Browser neu starten und jetzt gucken wir mal wie jetzt
Deckoverflow aussieht, der braucht übrigens login manageraft total overrated einfach direkt x starten
So, da sind wieder die five head birds am start
Das ist doch der standard font von immer
Das ist das anders als sonst, wie sieht das unter windows aus
Tatsächlich, ah die haben die haben die reinfolge der fonts geändert
Die haben einfach die reinfolge der fonts geändert die vom system verwendet also die reinfolge der auf dem system verfügbaren fonts haben die geändert
Ja, das ist ok ich finde es aber nice weil standardmäßig hatten die unter windows glaube ich sonst
Currier new oder sowas in der richtung
Bin ich in ordnung passt
Können sie ruhig so lassen, das wäre auch so lieber als das standard font den sie da vorher drin hatten
So leute
Ich mache mich jetzt schon vom agger ich habe bin zu low brain da heute mit der liste weiterzumachen aber wir haben ja schon einiges eingetragen
Ich werde das wahrscheinlich dann auf off stream fertig machen
Ich schaue jetzt erstmal ab
Spiel vielleicht noch runde battlefield oder so aber nicht on stream
Morgen stream ich muss mal gucken ich wollte mich endlich darum kümmern dass ich mein
3d kicks bekomme der reden kann
Muss ich mit muss ich mich ein bisschen mit pfeiffer auseinandersetzen
Der rüppel dankeschön 16 monate hypersubscription hier
Wann ist eigentlich der nächste feiertag
Säck Säck
Und 24 ja montag bringt mir nix mont ist ja scheiße warum muss das montag sein
Warum muss das montag sein was soll das können die finks montag nicht dienstag machen
Ein montag sagt
Montag ist der schlechteste feiertag überhaupt
Gibt es nicht einfach eine tabelle hier
So
Dann haben wir als nächstes das hatten wir schon das haben wir frohen leichnam kommt dann dritter sechster
Was ist eine dritte sechste ist ich hoffe dass es dann auch montag geht wenn das jetzt wieder montag ist kriege ich anfälle leute
Donnerstag sehr gut exzellent es heißt nächste woche brauche ich freitag wieder urlaub
Direkt urlaubsantrag urlaub antrag ist raus direkt montag mache ich dienstag mache ich den
Hast du schon gemacht
Was für ein appstarter verwendest du
Was für ein appstarter verwendest du äh was unter windows das startmenü
Ach unter linux in der file rofi roffi roffi
Welches themen boah keine ahnung
Keine ich habe schon ausgemacht weiß ich nicht komm das nächste mal gucken leute gucken wir das nächste mal
Ich spiele es noch eine runde plans versus zombie 1 endless oder irgendwas
Wir sehen uns macht es gut bis morgen
Bis morgen zu